i thought like oh everybody else does
this too
not realizing that like no that's
freaking weird thinking back as an adult
i'm like wow that's actually so surreal
eminem's daughter haley jade gets
nostalgic recalling her surreal
childhood and i'm like holy crap the 26
year old spills it all on her podcast
which launched last week and the title
it makes a cheeky nod to her famous
dad's alter ego
yeah the show's called just a little
shady but from what we've heard so far
it's all positive vibes from haley her
bff britney joins her for the premiere
episode where haley explains the purpose
behind the podcast we want to start by
addressing the elephant in the room
which is the double entendre and the
name just a little shady
so on one hand we have the aspect that
i want this to be a place where i can
share more about my life talk about
things i've never talked about and just
for you guys who've been with me for a
long time
get to know me a little better she
doesn't waste any time going into detail
about her not so normal childhood which
included trips with brittany on haley's
dad's tour bus it was always like
something going on that i was like
bernie needs to come to this i vividly
remember being in your kitchen and you
were like do you want to come on the
tour bus um and i was like casual casual
um normal conversations and i was like
what's a tour bus and somebody was with
us and they were like haley jade like
not everyone knows what a tour of us is
and you're like what like honestly to
you like that was i thought it was
somewhat normal yeah while it all seemed
normal in the moment haley says it
totally blows her mind when she looks
back when like something like that
happened i thought like oh everybody
else does this too
not realizing that like no that's
freaking weird and like looking back on
it it's like so fun to look back and
like when we have these conversations
like here or wherever like thinking back
as an adult i'm like wow that's actually
so surreal and like
those memories that like of me just
thinking like those were normal things
yeah now i look back and i'm like holy
crap but we can't really blame her it's
all hayley new growing up in the
spotlight and eminem stands are familiar
with all the references he's made to her
in his music the music video for his
2004 hit mockingbird was entirely made
up of home movies from hayley's
childhood hayley i know you miss your
mom and i know you miss your dad when
i'm gone but i'm trying to give you the
life that i never had fast forward to
2022 and the father-daughter duos seem
more bonded than ever and we know haley
is one of m's biggest fans
are you a nicki fan what am i a nicki
fan
pull up in the sri lanka what
earlier this year haley proudly watched
her dad from the stands as he performed
at the super bowl halftime show and
before her pop's big moment the michigan
native documented her excitement heading
into the stadium also sharing a full
view of the show's setup eminem then got
the crowd going with a special rendition
of his song lose yourself
[Music]
here's hoping the rapper shows the same
support as a guest on haley's podcast
[Music]